okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about
geometric scenes and um
this is mostly graphic design is that
correct
that's correct okay the second part is
more
a content discussion but the first part
yes right okay
all right so we have
what does step four mean here um
this is a geometric instruction
that he's using as an example uh we
discuss this shape and we will come back
in part two of the meeting
right so that for now let's just accept
the you know this structure as the steps
okay so yeah it's just an example sort
of for the sake of showing an example um
and uh right
to be sorry but i was just trying to say
that
uh step four is we haven't named any of
the steps
so since it's displaying the last right
okay all right so
mouse is outside the scene okay the
mouse is this the mouse
is is a hover this is on hover yes
so this isn't the actual this doesn't
look the same
what does that arrow down mean so okay
so the
it means that that's it's indicating
that you can change these things
um because the guiding principle was
that
uh when you're not when it's just
sitting in a notebook you want it to
look like a printout
um and then you only want exactly yes
so so for example if you'd actually
named that step so if you'd assigned a
name to step four it would look like a
figure right because that would sort of
be the title of the figure
um so that's the idea behind that and
then the little blue arrows are just to
show
that there is something that can happen
exactly yeah
and that happens in two stages so the
first is when you hover over it
um and then you get those elements
question question do you really want
i mean in terms of making the printout
look beautiful
do you really want an indicator on every
one of these or do you want something
globally here
you know globally in the corner here
that just says hello this is can be
made active yeah we can do that
and we could just have a little plus or
something in the corner
that indicates i don't know what the
best indicator of i don't know whether
we have a metaphor for that elsewhere
and he'll be cleaner so we don't have to
annotate every every random piece with
this
okay
okay well it's not we don't necessarily
right have all of those things i
i you know i don't know how tragic it
would be to have
those two very subtle indicators and
what what would happen if you click this
one that then represents both
well i assume you just go to the hover
state here i see
i see you're saying you're saying there
is a click action
well let me look at what you go go to
from here
okay so so you can see the hover space
and on the hover state you get the
you know the various bits of the ui so
you get you know sort of the zoom
controls bottom right you get
you can step through the steps at the
top there's reset the scene and then
there's
sort of the the paste menu um and
uh also um we've indicated on hover the
um anchoring of points so you can see a
and b
have got a blue outline around them
because they're anchored
um so again that kind of indicates that
you can sort of click within this
interesting okay um okay so hold on if
you were to click here
what would you get is there you're gonna
you're gonna tell me what what happens
if i click down on
on um on step four well you just you
just get a little pop-up menu of the
steps so step one step two
step three step four unless they were
named in which you'd get the next you
know you'd get i know
first yeah whatever you name the first
step to etc
okay but now by the way i thought we
were having
sorry just a procedural thing i thought
we were having christina in these
meetings when we're discussing
um ui features i've never even heard
this name coming up
right okay
can somebody please get her i'm sending
mail here
who is christina uh ux
uh design analyst
of intended part of qa
that deals with ux
um
okay
all right let's see so for example you
asking sort of what happens if you click
on steps well underneath it's got if you
click on conclusion
um okay
uh so again you get like a pop down menu
and i've just selected a random one
there
um and it's annotated the drawing
okay sorry the thing i was going to
comment on is you click that
that position there but then doesn't
this jump
over here well it does but you don't
click it because as soon as you hover
over it
that overlay you you get that overlay
right
um well yeah
i guess the question is is right
is is the title selectable right
if it's not then it doesn't matter if
that the button gets wider because you
you're still clicking if the
you know yeah right so in other words if
i click here
i still have the pull down i still have
the same pull down as if i were to click
here
that's what you're saying okay yeah it's
one that that sort of gray box indicates
that that is one control and
and remember as soon as your mouse goes
over it you see the gray thing
so
um sorry as soon as
which yes as soon as your mouse goes
over this you see the gray thing
but it's place where you click has
jumped but it doesn't matter to you
as long as the button is not selectable
right that doesn't matter
if the content of the button is
selectable then the fact that the
clicked zone has moved
would matter so
i guess we're assuming that the title is
not selectable
also i just point out that they
everything appears as one on hover it's
not like you hover over step four and
you just
get that little bit appearing at the top
if you hover over the scene
but but but if you go to where that blue
button
is before hover and that's the active
click
zone and now the click zone is still the
little
blue down arrow which has now moved
three quarters of the way across the
graphics then that very much matters
yeah but what we're saying is the click
zone
right well the question is is the click
zone the little down arrow
or is it i think it's the whole thing
yeah it's the great thing
right okay so which means in particular
as i was saying earlier that means that
the that title is not selectable
which is correct yes correct yeah all
right
it's just a button
oh it's not a it's a menu
okay the anchoring
what color are the anchors so there's a
whole if you scroll down this whole
section on anchoring
okay um
by the practical question how long is
this meeting going to be is this do we
have a lot of stuff or do we not have so
much stuff
um
okay you think it will take an hour okay
that's fine
um okay so at that point i'm just
driving home to the point that if you
move the mouse outside
of it and you've selected a conclusion
then just the conclusion stays
yeah the conclusion stays and it now
just looks like you have a figure with a
caption
okay um and then the editability comes
when you actually click
in the scene itself
and you pop an attached cell with those
controls there
but so then okay so the point about
anchoring is that
if we're allowing you to
programmatically pre-anchor stuff
um then having that blue outline is
probably not a good idea because it's
not too obvious what it means but if
if we're not allowing programmatic
pre-anchoring then
the only way you could set it is by
clicking on
you know what a b or c and anchored
points and therefore you'd know
that's what the blue outline meant
because you would have
put it yeah right if we don't know about
if you scroll down to the next one
and we do allow uh pre-anchoring then
we could you know maybe use it for an
icon like an anchor something like that
right although i i mean maybe it's just
because
the the these screen sharings make
things look smaller but i had no idea
what those anchor symbols were until
somebody said oh those are little
anchors yeah yeah okay the iconography
isn't perfect but
but um okay so what is the answer
programmatically to whether things are
pre-anchorable
so currently um in the
what we showed you last week if you have
a construction
uh and you're at a step where a point
has been
introduced in a previous step um that
point is is automatically anchored
unless you do something in later steps
um
but it's easy enough to just have
everything unanchored to begin with
right and which i think is correct
because the net result is if you have a
multi-step scene
then by default everything is anchored
when you first create it which just
seems ridiculous
so wait a minute so the anchoring is
then a user
added thing that if you have a
multi-step
so anchoring without multiple steps
doesn't make a lot of sense is that a
true statement
false well i mean initially you wouldn't
but you would
uh um anchoring says which
points to keep fixed as if you move
another point
which points to try to keep fixed in
order while
still resolving all the constraints okay
so this is this is something where we
can
interactively manipulate these figures
right and you can just
drag c there and that will say well
keep you know a and b fixed
which presumably means you can't
actually dr successfully drag c anywhere
uh well other than to the other
intersection of because it's
because it's that equilateral triangle
or whatever yeah right okay
right and now what happens in this case
okay so hold on
with respect to dragging discontinuously
that is c
only has one more solution here what
happens as you drag
well as you drag it'll just show it
that doesn't do any computations besides
showing the ghost of c so it doesn't
know what you're doing
if you happen to release it you know
on or very near that uh the
other what if you release it somewhere
else uh then
it will try to it will try for
like five seconds to uh come up with the
computation
that uh let's see be there and
um realize it can't and restore the
previous state
right restore the previous state okay so
it doesn't try to go to the nearest
viable state because it doesn't know
that yeah
okay and so you have just some zone
i mean if i if i drop c off about here
for example what will it do
that's probably a little too far there's
uh
um i forget exactly what the what the
zone is but is it settable
uh not currently no probably should be
okay um
okay so most of the time then
right but for example if you were to
unanchor b and drag
c then a would stay where it is but then
b would move presumably to accommodate
where are you assuming d is also
you unfix d because d is the distance
between a and b i think
but right
okay um
okay so here this will be a list of
points basically
and um what you're saying is
okay so if there is pre-anchoring
i don't understand why the pre-anchoring
just wouldn't show up here
and then to to remove the priyanka you
toggle it
so right that's um that's
uh what's currently implemented
the um the issue that
um some have come up with is that
it's a little it's not entirely
intuitive what anchoring means until you
do it yourself
so pre-anchoring things might cause
confusion
well but more importantly if every
currently the default is everything is
pre-anchored which means you can't
actually drag anything until you've
successfully okay so that's probably
wrong
look i think what we should say why
don't we change this name to be fixed
points just like we say fixed quantities
because they're the same concept
it was originally that i changed it to
anchor but yeah we'll change it back
okay um
well the the problem with uh fixed
points is people might think that means
you're not allowed to drag a fixed point
but you are allowed to drag a fixed
point it's only
fixed if you're trying to move other
points
i see
but but these quantities
well you can't drag the quantity
directly right although we could have a
slider which would allow you to drag the
quantity right
that's been brought up and probably not
for 12 too but
i think trying to add
slider capabilities for the quantities
would probably make sense
what would be the clearest thing to say
points held fixed or something what
would you say if you were allowed to
have
an any number of words what would you
say
um
points fixed under movement of
other points that's too long
yeah well he said any number of words
yeah okay but so the concept is
in that point in a sense they're
stationary points right
you can drag them but they don't move on
their own
right
it's not adapted we just keep it as
anchored points and we
unanchor a point when you try to move it
then an anchored point is just one that
doesn't move
but if you click on it and try to drag
it
would it go back to being anchored once
you drop it
no
that's not obviously correct you still
might not know to be able to drag it in
the first place
i think
yeah okay so the just a minute points
what is this called in drawing programs
or elsewhere or you know
control points those aren't obviously
the right thing but what
um well well that is anchoring but
but the difference is that they are
indeed anchored they won't move
you can't move them
do you mean if you want to have a shape
that you just can't edit at all until
you
uh until you unanchor it so to speak i
think steve means control point in the
sense of splines
yeah oh sorry sorry
um
um
um okay so the question here let's see
we want something which means
only you can move it it does not
automatically move
right
a point that automatically moves is
a dependent maybe
yeah dependent as as i mean that's the
concept
unfortunately that that sounds too
mathematical and will get people
confused
maybe not updating because actually
we've got pause updates which kind of
freezes the whole thing
yeah okay that's the different sort of
uh
action that you're doing but we could
sort of mirror the language that i
suppose you know points that don't auto
update
but that isn't right because locked you
see the whole point is you can move it
there's nothing wrong with you moving it
it just doesn't it doesn't move but when
you move something else
it doesn't get move what about auto
locked
or auto fixed
yeah i mean it's fixed under automatic
motion
right it's not that it automatically
fixes
it's fixed with respect to automatic
motion
as you can see you can also say that
it's placed
right you know i put it the truth is
this is every point
and you're indicating
points that are that move automatically
versus points that don't
correct could you flip it then and so
if you invert it it's the automatically
updated points
are the ones that are selected
yeah except we want to have this ring
somehow
to indicate um
okay so look i mean really this is
points
and quantities are the two things we
have here
one thing is points the other thing is
quantities and it's a list of all of
them
right yes
um although i mean it's certainly
comprehensible to label
just the subclass and you know the ones
which are active
actually i was confused when i initially
saw this i think it's better to just say
this is all points
um
oh do you mean you think anchor points
implies that that's a sub list
right that's what i thought okay okay
pinned as a suggestion from bob on our
live stream which is not a bad name
that makes sense now what do we do for
quantities
well i mean since we can't currently
can't
move quantities anyways you know fixed
is
unambiguous yeah
i like pinned pin suggests that you
could move it around
now the question is though um
you know this really is a list of all
points
you could change it to the verb so
anchor points fix quantities
no that's not going to work because
because it it represents state
right i mean it's got i think right
exactly but by selecting it you're
changing the state
which is i know i know but i i but but
but no
i think the point is that because you've
got a list of all the points here i
really think it should be called points
or it's going to be very confusing i
i strongly disagree with that stephen i
mean it's a very well established idiom
that you say
lang thing and then you have a check box
bar
and only the things which are actively
selected
have that property all right
okay well in that in that model it will
be pinned points and fixed quantities
hmm
i mean the alternative will be something
like points
and then the annotation that says
are pinned or something
or i suppose a an intermediate point
an intermediate state might be points
and then in
click to pin
yes well click to pin or unpin
right
but that would be very ugly to see all
the time
full tip i guess yeah but the problem
with that is you don't know it's there
you don't know what
you can do with these points i mean you
don't even know pinning isn't really a
thing
you don't even know you can pin
i mean except your point is you don't
even get this this attached cell unless
you click
correct
i mean there could be one of those
little question mark boxes
no nobody will ever click it they'll
never discover you can pin points
it really bothers me to say pinned
points and you've got a list of all the
points
um
how can we deal with this
how about something like points
colon and then uh
pinned with uh the blue border around it
what do you mean pim of the blue border
legends like thing
like literally you have points pull
then in parenthesis or points open
parentheses the word
pinned with the you know
oh just you just have an o there you
know a heavy o
meaning pinned oh yeah that would work
yeah with the same blue coloring as the
actual
i think this will work points and then
that says bubba
pin so you've got some idea that you can
do something to pin things
and if nothing is pinned then that
comment is irrelevant
yep okay pause updates what does that
mean
so this is if you want to move around if
you want to drag and drop
multiple points before it tries to
automatically update
so if if pause updates is not selected
then if you drag a point as soon as you
drop it the computation starts
but if you want to move multiple points
at once then you have to indicate that
somehow
and that pause updates i think it should
be a check mark
that says continuous update
no this is misleading with respect to
the meaning of continuous updated
manipulate
where it means value move right oh this
isn't while you move
okay right so it could be update on
release
but that sounds like we're getting a
newer version every
yeah okay but it is true the update
no but the issue i didn't understand
this so this this means
you are going to you you check that
button you move a bunch of points around
and then you say
update again and then you re-click that
button
ah correct that was completely not what
i got from that terminology
um
well maybe the iconography is
problematic because i
look if it was got i was going to say um
i was going to say if it was depressed
button that said updating or something
or updating enabled go ahead no you had
a suggestion
what if you had a essentially a setter
but not a setback
you know like a two to two i forgot what
the name is two buttons next to each
other and they alternate when you click
one and the first one says
move single and the second one says move
multiple
no because it wouldn't work just you
have to switch it back once you've
moved yeah no um
um
sandra suggesting calling it dynamic but
i don't
think that works because the basic point
is
no i mean this is
this is you press it
you move multiple points around so
generally it's not pressed but you press
it
um
look one possible this is an obscure
operation
so one thing we could do i i don't think
so
right i think it's pretty natural okay
hold on i've got an idea
um
okay we simply have a button that says
move multiple points
okay you press it and then it goes into
a state
where it says
end moving multiple points so yeah
update now that's fine
yes um or or
adjust multiple points or something
adjust what does it mean to to drag
drag multiple points and then
update now update figure
now
does drag multiple points make it sound
like you have to do them all at once
how would you do this that's my
concern is that somebody with a
multi-touch
device yeah so that you like
you know multi-selection and then
drag them or something what does several
sound better to you instead of multiple
arranged
how about rearrange multiple points
that sounds good to me dude i might add
a
manually in there just because
you know the
when the automatic updating happens
we're presumably
rearranging multiple points but this
means that the user is
well in that case we could say move if
we say manually we could say manually
move multiple points
what's the the ux of how do you make
that happen in that case
press that button and the button says
okay so now use now it says when you
when you press that button
it goes to saying um
update figure now well
um not only move multiple points
then what if it was just update
scene manually said no it's
that's not going to work because
oh i see what you're saying you're
saying you see because
i was thinking a case where the scene
only updated
maybe when you mouse out some behavior
where you don't have to click
but it but it also knows not to do
anything until you're you're done
i don't think we should do that i think
it's not i think i i see what you're
saying you're trying to avoid the fact
you have to have and what does happen
if you've if you click outside this and
you've
set manually move multiple points and
now you click outside
what does it do does it just leave it
with that extruded tongue down there
saying in other words when you click
back inside the extruded tongue would
still be there is that correct
presumably yes all right i mean i that
that the
at least that the the current
implementation is that pause updates is
is you know remembered serialized state
so
when you click out the button the
attached cell would disappear but the
state would persist
and then when you click back in it would
the
attached cell would reappear and it
would still be at the same state you
last
left yeah conor like students talking
about manual mode for automatic mode
that's unfortunately not the correct
description
because this is this is allows you to
move these points without
updating
so see okay the two sections above and
okay but i forgot what we changed the
names to but currently anchored points
and fixed quantities they've got a title
and then they've got the content
we could guide the user a bit we could
actually provide a title for that
section that says something like
you know updating scene um sorry this uh
sorry scene updating
um and then a button underneath um that
says
update scene and then a check box that
says auto update after drag
and that checkbox is on automatically so
it's a bit more verbose but instead of
trying to ram it all in one button
you just you have you had a heading like
the other two above it all right okay
let's
write this down so what are you saying
here you're saying
so so you you'd have a heading for that
because that's actually
let's write the whole thing out okay so
what you're saying is points
and then it says then it says
pinned
no fixed yeah
okay now what are you proposing here
okay the wording isn't quite right but
something like seen updating for the
heading for the last one
um and then and then i i guess what you
you haven't put in the others is that
under points you then have the list of
points and the quantities you have the
list of quantities in other words the
controls
and then the dating controls a button
perhaps that says
update scene and then a checkbox
underneath it that says
something like auto update after drag
and that is ticked by default update
scene is something
that's a button
which could gray out if the uh if the
check box is
yes that would make sense so the button
grip so update scene the button that
says ups
date scene grays out if the check box is
ticked in the check box yes as
you said it's auto update after dragon
that is automatically that's on by
default
i would flip it i would have the check
box
auto update and then when
the check box is unchecked you get
an update button to the right of it
oh i see but will people figure out
will people figure out there i i would
have the button visible always
um maybe underneath it um so it's a
column rather than a row perhaps
will everybody ever figure this out i
mean in other words they want to
the action that they're trying to do is
move multiple points around
okay they're frustrated they'll try it
once they'll try moving two points
they'll realize they can't do that
will they be able to make the inference
that you can move multiple points if you
can
remove the auto update after drag
well that was what the heading was for
to try and guide people to sort of say
well that's what it does so maybe the
heading scene updating could be
something a bit better um
all right i think we've we've done
enough with this here i
i'm not sure what the right answer is
but we're close it's one
idea so scene updating one would be
automatic and two would be
on mouse out
again it's like you move things around
as soon as your mouse leaves
but i don't think we only have that but
that's a different action then
but it allows you to move as much as you
want and then nothing will happen until
you leave
the scene right i don't think you want
to leave the scene of the geometry so to
speak
yeah as opposed to i i just don't think
that's the right action i think you
think this is stuff you're interactively
doing focusing on this
um so that raises a question that i have
for
noah and maybe the geometry folk which
is so this is an attached cell
which is you know in place because
you've
you've clicked into the scene if you now
go
and click somewhere completely different
in the notebook
presumably the attached cell dismisses
but
what happens
if you're in an unupdated state
well i guess you have two options one is
that you just you auto do the update
for them but i think my preference would
be you just cancel the action
okay okay
all right back to scene updating if it's
if it's seen updating automatic manual
what if checking manual adds a button
next to the plus minus like a little
refresh button
next to the plus minus above
so it's part of your right it's part of
the scene
ah that's a good idea
yeah that's a good idea and the refresh
button i mean i don't know whether we
can i can
graphically have a refresh button with a
you know like in a browser with a
yeah i think that would be enough so
that
yeah the icon is not great if you scroll
up slightly so you can see the top of
that
right that back arrow is refresh the
screen at the top right there
i thought that was to go to the original
state of the scene correct
yeah yeah oh sorry yeah yeah yeah that's
not
refresh in this sense refresh should be
a recycling button
yeah right what's that thing
uh scroll down a bit there's an action
menu below
uh keep scrolling right okay so that's
what we've currently have in the sort of
you know manipulated plus
icon um why isn't that a hamburger of
some kind i mean that seems to be the
iconography that we're using for those
kinds of menus
okay but is it wait
wait wait i i believe that right we've
split that one menu into two buttons
and there's the share button which is
right the penultimate button um
and that's for all the paste things
and then the
the button on the right is the
um go back to initial settings
which button are we talking about there
are two buttons here right and i just
said
the penultimate button that looks like a
share button
is for all the pasty things and then
that doesn't look like a share button
this looks like a go back button here i
mean the other one
the one on the end is all the paced
stuff
i don't know why you're saying
penultimate for that because it's
ultimate to the right sorry sorry
um all right you lost your pen
right or something okay so you mean this
button here
this button here yes i i was temporarily
confused because i'm on a different
operating system
where it looked where my share button
looks more like the go back button
um okay okay what i'm suggesting is that
this be either the hamburger
or which by the way is probably what we
should change the plus
in a manipulate too yeah i agree
i mean that's just become the general
iconography for you know men who do
something
so go ahead no
the reason why we had a slightly
different icon was because
so a hamburger one is yeah you could do
all sorts of things in it but that only
contains all the paste operations
what about fine conjectures does it
contain that that's hardly a paste
operation
well you're pasting you're right
what what you're still pasting
you just have to do a computation first
i think this distinction will be lost on
people
i think we should just have a hamburger
menu and we can put other stuff in that
menu if we need to
okay you're saying get rid of the uh
get rid of the initial settings button
and just have it in the hamburger menu
well if you want to have that button as
a convenience that's fine
i wouldn't take it out of the menu
people will look for it in the menu just
have all the stuff in the menu
if it really turns out initial settings
is the most important thing
then you can i don't think it is i don't
think so okay fine then just let's put
it all in the menu
okay what's that thing there
re-center the view
oh do we have another piece of
iconography for that
for things like geo i mean we'll need
that iconography for
lots of uh dynamic graphics
what about dynamic image does it have an
iconography for that
i've never seen it before that's not
that i iconography
there's currently a project for pan and
zoom graphics in the cloud
um ux for that and actually the icon i
used for reset view was
the arrow that i've used at the top
there um
okay fine that seems reasonable to me
oh yeah and we're combining those two
buttons anyway so that's not a problem
we can use that icon to reset the w
perfect okay that seems reasonable to me
plus minus and reset that that seems
plausible to
guess that that's what that would mean
right do you think the reset the view is
to just
just uh recenter the graphics okay and i
assume that pan here
is there a pan based on just thumbing i
mean you know
okay the cursor there you go you can see
it there it
turns into an open hand no i think
scroll down a bit sorry
the second yeah okay fine
mouse down does this okay
it's just showing a more minimal example
if you haven't specified steps and
you've hidden the conclusions then
that's what it would look like
okay by the way
this border what color should it be i
i really come to like the purple border
of graphic of of
graphs i think it's very stylish
i'm actually getting rather fed up with
the orange border of graphics i think we
might want to change that orange
not not i mean but i really like the
distinction of i've got a graph
it's it's cool and purple so to speak
my question is on click what is this
is this a graphic or is this something
different it's not really a graphic it's
something different i think it should
have another
exotic theming color what does image use
is it orange i think it is orange isn't
it
i think it would not matter those are
images just click on one
what's that though okay
well that's the answer yeah i mean
that's sort of
well
yes although at least you have the the
the menu to tell you that it's not a
graphics
yes i mean i would personally a slightly
different color here might
be a good thing i mean i think we should
use more colors there
generally speaking what do you mean by
that
you mean in the border in the border
i also think this thing is extremely
drab and all gray
it's like let's have some more you know
joy of editing or something
i mean even just uh even just a wash of
color behind it would be helpful i think
go ahead i'm going to say saying i'm
very colorblind so
it's going to stay gray until someone
tells me specifically what to do
otherwise
because i have no sense for these things
fair enough
okay geometric step what is this is this
a completely different piece of design
yes so this is uh your language design
right uh you had mentioned last time you
didn't like
uh that to represented geometric
construction
uh it was just um
just turning the second argument from a
list of non-lists into a list of lists
you wanted something more explicit
uh you had mentioned actually having a
geometric construction head
we talked about this at our weekly
meeting we didn't necessarily
the problem with that was it made it
kind of awkward
to um
to for one thing our constructions
aren't actually constructions they're
just multi-step
scenes right but also i mean
uh if the main thing you would want to
do
is to annotate uh a step
and if you have you know geometric
instruction
head then you have to find some way of
lining up these step descriptions with
the actual what about the
association
well would you it
would you have an association for each
you know if you have an association for
each step
how much annotation you're going to need
but but these geometric steps can they
be floated with other things or do they
all have to come together
um well i mean
can you intersperse other things between
geometric steps or is it always
well i would uh i would
uh i would say like that look at the
last bullet point so if there's at least
one geometric step
wrapper then we assume we're a
construction
and any consecutive non-geometric
step things get grouped together
and that's kind of currently how it
works with the
the list of lists if you have something
if you have some naked things
then the consecutive ones just get
grouped together
in the same step which i think makes
sense
you know having been recently reading
euclid
this business you know where he just
says
his statement is to inscribe a triangle
in a circle
it's like what is this this is not a
statement it is what is it what kind of
a
what what kind of a thing is that what
it really said what it really
the full version of that is a
construction exists with ruler and
compass that will allow you
to blah blah blah blah correct
so how does that relate to what you're
doing well
maybe this is splitting hairs but i
you know it's not just an existence
statement he's given the connection
the geometric scene is the construction
it may be split i understand that i
understand that although euclid himself
confusingly enough
did not give any proofs or constructions
he just made those statements
or at least so far as one can tell i
mean that that's maybe that's a
historical point of no interest but i
mean that
because because then his quotes proof is
then a construction
right yep and so you're you know that's
merging the notion of of what's proof
and what's a
uh you know what's a statement so to
speak
i mean then the right like a geometric
scene need not make any statement
at all it need not have a third argument
in other words it's just set up i just
say i want to have a geometric scene
that represents the process of first
drawing this triangle then drawing this
line and
so on so random when you run random
instance on a construction
it uh it interprets it differently it
just looks at the first step
draws the first step and then when it
moves to a subsequent step
everything from the from previous steps
is fixed
rather than just a generic geometric
scene if you run random instance on it
it
you know tries to arrange everything at
once
all right listen i maybe i just need my
lunch too badly but
this this seems okay to me at least as
an experimental thing i'm not 100
sold on the way that you know that you
can have
you i mean but am i correct in thinking
you can intersperse
statements and geometric steps
well it will normalize into a list of
geometric steps
right it would geometric scene would
auto evaluate to
a list of geometric steps but you would
well what happens to that euclidean
distance thing that's there
where would that get put it would that
would be
in its own geometric step yeah that
would be putting its own geometric step
and if there were
multiple things there they'd get grouped
together in the same geometric step but
so then the only thing that geometric
step is doing for you is providing an
annotation is that true
well providing annotation and
you know separating the steps as they're
uh
as random but this isn't a step i mean
this euclidean distance thing isn't a
step
it is you're saying you're introducing
the points a and b
and you're saying and we're going to
keep track of the distance between them
all right
right i mean look at what the next step
is the next step is two circles
but what do i see in the pictures when i
get to that step
so if i see multiple steps here that
will be showing up as
step blah blah blah
yeah that would be the optional second
argument and presumably
it would um you know in the display we'd
have some
character limit and then it would just
have a dot dot dot after that's what i
would guess
and then if you scroll over it would uh
have the full description and
in terms of what you see it will show
you what
it needs to draw in order to represent
that statement so if it's a statement
about circles it'll draw those circles
if they're not there
right let's see i think it's so obvious
i think you're going to have to have a
um a tool tip
to give the full description because
it's not going to fit necessarily here
right i think it'll be a tooltip okay um
and then if we have plot themes for the
whole thing
we could have a plot theme where
anything
new that we introduce in that step when
we're looking at that step that's
highlighted
um if we want that
well i would have thought that should be
one of these controls i would have
thought that should be in the hamburger
menu
okay yeah that's certainly something we
could put in the hamburger menu
fine um all right
boy it's uh after we've done euclid we
go back and do the babylonian
problems i i i think bernat was just
finally solving
one of those uh weird problems with the
geometry of loons that was on some
babylonian exercise thing
from 3500 years ago
we can get a cuneiform intern for uh
next summer yeah right well meanwhile
young christopher happens to be working
on this
on these astronomical diary making
these babylonian astronomical diaries
computable
which has many joys of such weird things
including their incredibly bizarre date
system
in which in which apparently they
randomly added months from time to time
because things had gone wrong or because
they wanted to collect more tax that
year
anyway okay sounds good all right
terrific
did you uh send this updated notebook
you've been working on uh
to us um
i will try to do so it's fine give it
your best shot
um all right
let's see um
uh who should i send it to uh d mcdonald
okay or t alpha euclid actually
probably so everyone can see it
okay um
all right there it goes all right
thanks a lot guys good stuff and um
uh talk to you all soon thanks for
watching the live stream as well
okay actually we have another live
stream coming up about
physics and multi-way game systems
in a few